This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. This week for Halloween, the Science of Fear. We'll talk about what scares us and why sometimes anticipating being afraid can be worse than the thing itself. Uh, I don't know if I can do this. We're going to talk about how changing a few subtle things can make us feel disoriented. Yeah, your body is basically just preparing itself to face whatever it's going to encounter around the next bend.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。本周是万圣节特辑，主题是恐惧的科学。我们将探讨是什么让我们感到害怕，以及为什么有时对恐惧的预期可能比事情本身更糟糕。呃，我不知道我能不能做到这一点。我们将讨论一些细微的改变如何让我们感到迷失方向。是的，你的身体基本上只是在做准备，去面对它在下一个转角将要遭遇的任何事情。
And how this sense of disorientation can increase your fear. Oh my god, it is bad. We'll also explore the upside of fear. Sometimes being scared can actually be a good thing. We're going to do things a little differently in this episode. We decided to recruit a very brave guinea pig. Oh my god. Oh my god.
以及这种方向感丧失是如何加剧你的恐惧的。天哪，太糟糕了。我们还将探讨恐惧积极的一面。有时感到害怕实际上是一件好事。我们在这一期节目中将采用一点不同的方式。我们决定招募一只非常勇敢的小白鼠。天哪。天哪。
What's that? Maggie Penn minutes one of the producers of this podcast. Maggie, welcome. Hi, Shankar. I don't sound very brave in that clip. I have to say. That's not my finest hour. I think you do sound like a guinea pig, though.
那是什么？玛吉·彭曼，本播客的制作人之一。玛吉，欢迎。嗨，尚卡尔。我在那个片段里听起来一点也不勇敢。我必须说。那不是我最精彩的表现。不过，我觉得你听起来确实像一只小白鼠。
Absolutely. I sound like I'm being subjected to something, for sure. All right. You are clearly not someone who enjoys being afraid. No, I can't even watch previews for horror movies. So this might explain why over the last few days you have been a little annoyed with it. So I had this idea that it would be really fun to do an episode about the science of fear for Halloween. And you thought it would be really fun if I went and investigated for myself.
绝对的。我听起来就像是在经受某种折磨，这是肯定的。好吧。你显然不是一个喜欢害怕的人。对，我甚至连恐怖片的预告片都看不了。所以这也许能解释为什么在过去的几天里你对我有点生气。所以我当时有个想法，觉得做一期关于万圣节恐惧科学的节目会很有趣。而你觉得如果我去亲自调查一番会非常有趣。
Exactly. I mean, what use is a story about fear without somebody who's actually frightened out of their wits? Yeah, I can see why that would be fun for you, but it was slightly less fun for me. All right, tell me what you found. Yeah, I drove to Pennsylvania to meet with this woman, Margie Kerr, and she's a sociologist at the University of Pittsburgh.
没错。我的意思是，如果没有一个真正被吓得魂不附体的人，关于恐惧的故事还有什么用呢？是的，我能理解为什么这对你来说很有趣，但对我来说就没那么有趣了。好吧，告诉我你发现了什么。对，我开车去了宾夕法尼亚州，去见这位名叫玛吉·克尔的女士，她是匹兹堡大学的一位社会学家。
But she also has this sort of side gig where she curious a haunted house called scarehouse and uses it to study fear. She actually has a new book out now called Scream, chilling adventures in the science of fear and believe it or not the cover glows in the dark. Very unnerving. All right, so she's a sociologist, she runs a haunted house, and she enjoys scaring people out of their wits. Yeah, so it was funny because Margie was just not what I was expecting. She does not look like the kind of person who studies fear for living. Hi! Hi!
但她也有点像个副业，她经营着一家名为“惊吓屋”的鬼屋，并利用它来研究恐惧。她实际上现在有一本新书出版了，叫做《尖叫：恐惧科学中的惊悚奇遇》，信不信由你，它的封面是夜光的。非常让人不安。好吧，所以她是一位社会学家，她经营一家鬼屋，而且她喜欢把别人吓得魂不附体。对，所以这很有趣，因为玛吉完全出乎我的意料。她看起来不像是那种以研究恐惧为生的人。嗨！嗨！
Nice to meet you. Come on in. She was the sweet, lovely, welcoming person, but every once in a while she would be describing something in the haunted house and would get really excited about something like this. All of the trigger treaters that we've been seeing, all of these very cute kind of cartoonish characters are being decapitated and stabbed and eaten. Oh, that is just awful Maggie. I know.
很高兴见到你。请进。她是一个甜美、可爱、热情的人，但每隔一段时间，当她描述鬼屋里的某个东西时，她就会对类似这样的事情感到非常兴奋。我们所看到的所有的不给糖就捣蛋的人，所有这些非常可爱、有点像卡通的角色都被斩首、刺伤和吃掉了。哦，那太糟糕了，玛吉。我知道。
So clearly, Margie is the kind of person who loves this stuff. She loves horror movies. She's always loved creepy, crawly monsters. It's just kind of like her thing. OK, mental note to self avoid Margie Kerr on quiet streets, especially late at night. Okay, no, but seriously, she was lovely. I met with her on a Saturday afternoon. I got a tour of her lab. We had this great chat about fear and science, what makes horror movies so popular. And then I came back at night. This is the part of the tape where you're going to hear my voice get about an octave higher.
所以很显然，玛吉就是那种热爱这些东西的人。她喜欢恐怖电影。她一直都很喜欢毛骨悚然的怪物。这基本上就是她的菜。好吧，在心里默默记下：在安静的街道上要避开玛吉·克尔，尤其是深夜。好吧，不，但说真的，她很可爱。我是在一个周六下午见到她的。我参观了她的实验室。我们关于恐惧和科学进行了了一场棒极了的聊天，探讨了为什么恐怖电影如此受欢迎。然后我晚上又回去了。录音的这一部分，你会听到我的音调大约升高了八度。
Alright, so I'm imagining that this is because you're afraid, your muscles are tensing up, your vocal cords are going to get clenched, and that's why you're going to sound like a guinea pig. Yeah, I mean, that all sounds very scientific. I think my experience was just sort of like low-grade panic attack for about 25 minutes, so... Whatever floats your boat. But you're gonna hear another voice in this tape too, and that was Margie falling behind me collecting data. And then I was also wearing this crazy lab coat with like little things stuck on my fingers and torso collecting my heart rate and something
好吧，所以我想象这是因为你害怕了，你的肌肉在紧绷，你的声带会收紧，这就是为什么你听起来会像一只小白鼠。是的，我的意思听起来都很科学。我觉得我的经历就像是一场持续了大约25分钟的低级别恐慌发作，所以……随你喜欢吧。但你也会在这段录音中听到另一个声音，那是玛吉落在我身后收集数据。然后我还穿着这件疯狂的实验服，上面有小东西粘在我的手指和躯干上，收集我的心率和某种被称为
called galvanic skin response, which is basically just how sweaty someone is getting, and they use that as a measurement for how scared you are. So I want to hear what the data was, but before that Maggie, just tell me, tell me a little bit about the house. Yeah, so the beginning of the haunted house incorporated a lot of the building's history, which was really cool. So this building used to be the Alx Club Lodge and it has this sort of faded glamour. There's this spooky 1920s music kind of coming through an old phonograph. It sounds almost underwater.
皮肤电反应的东西，这基本上就是一个人出汗的程度，他们用这个来衡量你有多害怕。所以我想听听数据是什么，但在此之前，玛吉，先告诉我，跟我说说这座房子。对，鬼屋的开头融入了大量建筑的历史，这真的很酷。所以这座建筑曾经是Alx俱乐部会所，它有一种褪色的魅力。旧留声机里传出一种20世纪20年代诡异的音乐。听起来几乎就像在水底一样。
There's a party scene. It's full of people and animatronics and dolls and costumes. And one of the very creepy things about this is you're never quite sure which one you're dealing with until you're very close. Oh my god. Get up! Lots of taxidermy on the walls. And then it went from creepy to brutal with some human taxidermy. What did you just say?
这是一个派对场景。里面挤满了人、电子动画、玩偶和服装。其中非常诡异的一点是，直到你靠得很近之前，你都无法确定你面对的到底是哪个。天哪。起来！墙上有大量的标本剥制。然后它从诡异变得残酷，带有一些人类标本剥制。你刚才说什么？
Human taxidermy. They were actually stuffing human beings. Well, that looked like the plan. There were some sort of mangled bodies hanging from the ceiling, blood, gore. Yeah, this is where I sort of started to freak out. I don't know if I can do this. You can do it! I love the fact that she's encouraging you, that she's going you on.
人类标本剥制。他们实际上在做人类的标本。嗯，看起来像是有这个计划。天花板上挂着一些被严重肢解的尸体，血迹斑斑，血肉模糊。是的，这就是我开始抓狂的地方。我不知道我能不能做到这一点。你能做到的！我很喜欢她一直在鼓励你，一直在怂恿你。
She's very gleeful about her work. That's what I'll say. And throughout the whole house, there's this kind of creepy soundtrack of whispers, music. And then, of course, there are the actors. Oh, are you the chosen one? Well, this guy was sort of like half human and who's just getting all up in my space. Oh, I can smell it, let me see. Oh yes, let me see.
对于自己的工作，她表现得兴高采烈。这就是我想说的。在整个房子的游览过程中，都有这种由低语和音乐组成的诡异背景音。然后，当然，还有演员们。哦，你是被选中之人吗？这个家伙有点像半个人类，而且一直在侵入我的私人空间。哦，我能闻到，让我看看。哦，是的，让我看看。
Oh, yes. Follow me. All right, that sounds really creepy, my lady. Okay, see this isn't kid stuff. I am so sorry I did this to you Maggie. Oh, well, it's okay. We're gonna bring it up with the union, but in the meantime. So yeah, there are a lot of what Margie referred to as booscares, which is basically something or someone jumping out surprising you.
哦，是的。跟我来。好吧，听起来真的很诡异，女士。好吧，看，这可不是小孩子的把戏。我很抱歉对你做了这些，玛吉。哦，好吧，没关系。我们要向工会提出抗议，但在此期间。所以，是的，有很多玛吉所说的“惊吓”，这基本上就是某物或某人突然跳出来吓你一跳。
Are we ready? Leaving to reactions like that. You know, that's interesting, Maggie, because when I think of scary stuff, I really divided into two kinds of things at my head, so there's the scary stuff like we just heard, where something jumps out at you and makes a scary sound. There's also the other kind of scary stuff where the fear sort of builds up really, really slowly and you know that something bad is going to happen, but you just don't know when. That's exactly right. And it's funny because the boo scares are
我们准备好了吗？引发了那样的反应。你知道，这很有趣，玛吉，因为当我想象可怕的事情时，我真的在脑海里把它分成两类，所以有一种是我们刚刚听到的那种可怕的事情，有什么东西突然跳出来吓你，并发出可怕的声音。还有另一种可怕的事情，恐惧感会慢慢地、慢慢地累积，你知道会有坏事发生，但你只是不知道什么时候。完全正确。有趣的是，“惊吓”
actually pretty light. Even though I was screaming, you can hear Margie sort of laughing at herself in the background for being startled. and most people who voluntarily go through on a house have that reaction. But what was really unnerving was the subtle stuff, the sort of distorted mirrors and darkness and fog and noise. I don't know which way I'm supposed to be going. Oh my gosh, I can really hear the panic in your voice there. Yeah, the disorientation stuff really freaked me out,
其实相当轻松。尽管我一直在尖叫，但你可以听到玛吉在背景中因为受到惊吓而有点自嘲地笑。大多数自愿走过鬼屋的人都有这种反应。但真正让人不安的是那些微妙的东西，比如扭曲的镜子、黑暗、雾气和噪音。我不知道我该往哪个方向走。哦天哪，我真的能听到你声音里的恐慌。是的，迷失方向感的东西真的把我吓坏了，
and some of the rooms were completely dark. You had to sort of feel your way through, not knowing what might be around the next corner. I actually talked to Margie about that sensation after we got out of the house. Yeah, the blackout rooms are so terrifying because we can't use anything to sort of gauge our position in space or our appropriate section is completely out of whack because we really need just something, just even the slightest little light to kind of give us an idea of what's up and what's down. And when you take that away through darkness or you know with use of fog, there's a ton of fog.
而且有些房间是一片漆黑。你必须摸索着前进，不知道下一个拐角处会有什么。从鬼屋出来后，我 tatsächlich 还和玛吉谈了谈那种感觉。对，全黑的房间太可怕了，因为我们无法用任何东西来衡量我们在空间中的位置，或者我们的方向感完全失控了，因为我们真的只需要某些东西，哪怕是一点点微弱的光，来给我们一个什么是上、什么是下的概念。当你通过黑暗把这些拿走，或者你知道通过使用雾气，那里有大量的雾。
Strobe lights too, strobe lights combined with hyperventilation are the best at inducing a feeling of depersonalization or when you sort of feel like you're outside of yourself. So here's what I'm thinking, Maggie, and I'm actually thinking about something much more serious than haunted houses at this point. The whole thing that she just talked about, the idea of disorientation and triggering disorientation as a way to trigger fear, I feel like psychologists have actually applied this in all kinds of ways, some of which are actually quite unethical. If you look at the ways in which people have practiced torture, people have used exactly the same techniques of using strobe lights and loud music, darkness, cold, sounds of crying babies. And when you pipe these things in to people over extended periods of time, it actually is as traumatic as actually being beaten or abused
还有频闪灯，频闪灯加上过度通气是诱发人格解体或当你觉得自己仿佛置身躯体之外的感觉的最佳方式。所以我是这么想的，玛吉，此时此刻我其实在思考比鬼屋严肃得多的事情。她刚谈到的整件事，关于迷失方向感以及通过触发迷失方向感来引发恐惧的想法，我觉得心理学家实际上已经把这应用到了各种方式中，其中一些实际上相当不道德。如果你看看人们实施酷刑的方式，人们使用的正是使用频闪灯和高分贝音乐、黑暗、寒冷、婴儿哭声等完全相同的技术。当你将这些东西长时间输入到人们体内时，它实际上和遭受殴打或虐待或者以某种方式遭受身体侵犯一样具有创伤性。
or being physically violated in some way. I can really imagine that because even though this was a haunted house, it was a very controlled environment, I knew I was safe the whole time. There is just something so disorienting about being in a completely dark room, or being constantly bombarded with strobe lights and sound, and the way Margie described it is basically whatever your conscious brain is saying, even if you're saying, I know I'm safe, I'm in a haunted house, no one can touch me, your sort of lizard brain kind of takes over.
我真的能想象这一点，因为尽管这是一个鬼屋，但这是一个非常受控的环境，我知道我自始至终都是安全的。身处一个完全黑暗的房间里，或者不断受到频闪灯和声音的轰击，这种感觉实在太让人迷失方向了，正如玛吉所描述的那样，基本上无论你的有意识的大脑在说什么，即使你在说，我知道我是安全的，我在鬼屋里，没有人能碰我，你的那种“蜥蜴大脑”（本能大脑）某种程度上接管了控制权。
And you don't care if you know you're safe. You just feel that fear. And in the context of a haunted house, sometimes ordinary things can be incredibly unnerving. So I have this awesome piece of tape I want to play for you. So this awesome piece of tape I want to play for you. So that's something they use as part of the soundtrack of the haunted house. It's creepy, right? It's totally creepy and I can totally understand why.
而且你根本不在乎你是否知道自己是安全的。你只感觉到那种恐惧。在鬼屋的语境下，有时平常的东西也会变得极其让人不安。所以我有一段很棒的录音想要放给你听。所以我有一段很棒的录音想要放给你听。所以那是他们用作鬼屋背景音乐一部分的东西。很诡异，对吧？这完全很诡异，我完全可以理解为什么。
You're hearing the sound of the background. It's dark, you're disoriented, and now everything around you feels like it's potentially a threat. Absolutely. And the funny thing that Margie told me later about that sound, it's actually SpongeBob SquarePants audio slowed down 800 times. So there's nothing scary about the audio, but when it's slowed down and you're in that environment, you're expecting to be scared and so you are. So tell me one thing, I'm not sure if this came up in your conversation with Margie, why
你听着背景的声音。四周一片黑暗，你失去了方向感，现在你周围的一切感觉都可能是一种威胁。绝对的。玛吉后来跟我说的关于那个声音的有趣之处在于，它实际上是《海绵宝宝》的音频放慢了800倍。所以音频本身并没有什么可怕的，但当它被放慢，而你又身处那样的环境中时，你就会期待着害怕，于是你就真的害怕了。所以告诉我一件事，我不确定这是否在我和玛吉的对话中出现过，为什么
is it that people pay money to show up at these haunted houses? They pay money to go and see horror movies. It's a great question. And this was actually one of the big reasons I wanted to do this story is because I feel like as someone who doesn't enjoy being scared, it's so hard for me to relate to. But obviously people like this.
人们要花钱去这些鬼屋？他们花钱去看恐怖电影。这是一个很好的问题。这也是我想做这个报道的重大原因之一，因为我觉得作为一个不喜欢害怕的人，我很难对这一点产生共鸣。但显然人们喜欢这样。
There's a huge horror movie industry. People love haunted houses. And Margie actually gave me some insight. You know, people who voluntarily engaged with these experiences are benefiting. So we measured people before they went in and after they came out, and their mood improved
有一个庞大的恐怖电影产业。人们喜欢鬼屋。玛吉实际上给了我一些见解。你知道，那些自愿参与这些体验的人正在从中受益。所以我们在人们进去之前和出来之后对他们进行了测量，他们的情绪得到了
significantly. And we did find that there were differences in how people were processing cognitive and emotional information after they went through, suggesting that pushing someone to that higher-rouse or threat response, it is affecting how we think, especially how we think about negative things. Wow, I would not have expected that.
显著改善。我们确实发现，人们在经历这些之后，对认知和情绪信息的处理方式存在差异，这表明将某人推向那种更高唤醒或威胁反应，会影响我们的思考方式，尤其是我们对消极事物的思考方式。哇，我可没料到这一点。
So going through a haunted house is really like taking a medication for anxiety. I can tell you for me, it was not like taking medication for anxiety, but apparently for these people who really are thrill seekers and enjoy that adrenaline rush, I think for those people it really does relax them. When we come out, we're not essentially thinking as much, and that's something that lots of research has shown that when you're scared, you're executive functioning, your prefrontal cortex is taking a backseat to your limbic system, so the body is prioritizing all of those mechanisms that are going to help us survive. And so what we're thinking is that for, you know, group of people, and we did find that,
所以经历鬼屋真的就像在吃治疗焦虑的药。我可以告诉你，对我来说，这可不像是吃焦虑药，但显然对那些真正寻求刺激并享受肾上腺素飙升的人来说，我认为对这些人来说它确实能让他们放松。当我们出来时，我们基本上不会想那么多了，许多研究都表明，当你在害怕时，你的执行功能，你的前额叶皮层会退居到边缘系统的次要地位，因此身体会优先处理所有那些将帮助我们生存的机制。所以我们的想法是，对于，你知道的，一部分人，我们确实发现，
you know, those who came in who were very stressed and anxious had the biggest improvements in mood ratings. And we call it a stress recalibration. So in other words, most people who go through scarehouse end up feeling better after they are done. You went through scarehouse, and in some ways you ended up feeling worse after you were done. I'm wondering if there might be a sort of self-selection
你知道的，那些进来时压力很大、很焦虑的人，情绪评分的改善最大。我们称之为压力重新校准。换句话说，大多数经历过惊吓屋的人在结束后最终都感觉好多了。你经历了惊吓屋，在某种程度上，你结束后反而感觉更糟糕了。我在想这里可能存在一种自我选择
effect here, which is most people who are going to scarehouse are going there voluntarily. They have figured out over time that going to haunted houses and scary experiences makes them feel better. You on the other hand did not go voluntarily and maybe that's because you figured out that these experiences don't make you feel better afterwards. Yeah, and Margie says this is actually one of the big limitations of this study. Is there only collecting data from people who are already voluntarily showing up at scarehouse?
效应，也就是说，大多数要去惊吓屋的人都是自愿去的。他们随着时间的推移已经发现，去鬼屋和可怕的体验能让他们感觉更好。另一方面，你并不是自愿去的，也许那是因为你已经发现这些体验并不能让你事后感觉更好。是的，玛吉说这实际上是这项研究的巨大局限性之一。他们只从那些本来就自愿出现在惊吓屋的人那里收集数据吗？
Was any of this even a little bit fun Maggie? You know, I hesitate to say fun, but I always knew I was safe, fundamentally, and that's kind of the line that a haunted house asks you to walk. You simultaneously know you're going to be okay, but you're losing control enough that you're able to get that thrill. And that's another awesome thing about the human mind is that we can suspend our disbelief and sort of allow ourselves to believe that we've lost this control while still knowing you know, in our deepest kind of part that we're actually safe, we're okay.
这一切哪怕有一点点有趣吗，玛吉？你知道，我犹豫要不要说有趣，但我一直都知道我是安全的，从根本上讲是这样的，这就是鬼屋要求你走的那条钢丝。你一方面知道自己会没事的，但另一方面你又失去了足够的控制，从而能够获得那种刺激。人类大脑的另一个神奇之处在于，我们可以悬置怀疑，某种程度上允许自己相信我们已经失去了这种控制，同时在内心最深处仍然知道我们其实是安全的，我们没事的。
Because if people really didn't feel that they could leave or that they could leave safely. It wouldn't be fine. It would be true trauma. So here's the thing I find really fascinating, Maggie. It's very clear haunted houses are actually safe, but they feel like they're unsafe. But there are also many experiences that actually are unsafe that feel very safe. And you know, throughout this episode, Maggie, I know I've sounded like a really callous calling. But the truth is, I actually was afraid of something. It had
因为如果人们真的觉得他们无法离开，或者他们无法安全离开。那将不再有趣。那将是真正的创伤。所以这里有件事我觉得真的很迷人，玛吉。很明显，鬼屋其实是安全的，但它们感觉起来是不安全的。但也有许多体验实际上是不安全的，却让人感觉非常安全。而且你知道，在这一集的节目中，玛吉，我知道我听起来像是一个冷酷无情的同事。但事实是，我其实害怕某样东西。这与
nothing to do with haunted houses, because pretty much no one dies in haunted houses. That's what you think. I was really afraid that you were going to be driving to Pittsburgh after a long day at work, five hours behind the wheel. And I was thinking about the statistics that say more than 30,000 Americans die in traffic crashes every year. That's what you should have been afraid about.
鬼屋完全无关，因为几乎没有人会在鬼屋里死掉。你是这么想的。我真的很担心你在结束一天漫长的工作后，要开车五个小时去匹兹堡。我想到了那些统计数据，每年有超过30,000名美国人在交通事故中丧生。这才是你该害怕的事。
Yeah, that's very rational of you. But it's funny because I wasn't worried about that at all. I was totally fixated on what ghost or goblin was going to come around the next corner. You know, my theory is that it actually has something to do with evolution that our brains have been sculpted through millennia of evolution to pay attention to things that jump out from behind rocks and that's what the haunted house does, our brains have not evolved to be fearful of driving now the highway at 70 miles an hour in a box. So that makes perfect sense to me and makes me feel a little better about being completely irrational. Well hang on a second Maggie, you left me in a little bit of suspense because you told me at the start that they collected all this data on you What did Margie find?
是的，你这很理性。但这很有趣，因为我一点也不担心这个。我完全全神贯注于哪个鬼怪会从下一个转角跳出来。你知道，我的理论是，这实际上与进化有关，我们的大脑经过了几千年演化的塑造，会去关注那些从岩石后面跳出来的东西，这就是鬼屋所做的事，而我们的大脑并没有进化到会对现在以每小时70英里的速度在一个盒子里开上高速公路感到恐惧。这对我来说完全说得通，也让我对自己的彻底不理性感到稍微好受了一些。好吧，等一下，玛吉，你留给我了一点悬念，因为你在开始时告诉我他们收集了你所有的这些数据。玛吉发现了什么？
So it took a couple of weeks actually for Margie and her colleague Greg Siegel who's a neuroscientist to analyze my data But I do have it here So let me just show this to you first. Okay, can I see you? So this is Sort of a normal person's galvanic skin response going through the hunt Okay, so it shows this wavy line sort of steadily increasing, which presumably means that they're getting more and more scared as they go through the house. Right, so here's mine. Alright.
所以玛吉和她的同事格雷格·西格尔（他是一位神经科学家）花了几个星期的时间才分析完我的数据。但我确实把它带到这儿了。所以让我先把它展示给你看。好吧，我能看看吗？所以这大致是一个正常人在经历鬼屋时的皮肤电反应。好吧，它显示出这条波浪线在稳稳地上升，这大概意味着他们在穿过鬼屋时变得越来越害怕。对，所以这是我的。好吧。
Whoa! This is completely different. It's not, it looks like you're spiking and then you come down, then you spike again, and then you come down, and it's up and down the whole time. Yeah, it's all over the place. So you can see there are certain points where I got really, really scared. And then there were other times when I really calmed down a lot. And they said that part of this might be because I went through a slightly different experience than the one at
哇！这完全不同。它看起来不是那样的，它看起来像你在飙升然后下来，然后又飙升，然后又下来，上上下下一整天。是的，到处都是。所以你可以看到有些地方我真的、真的非常害怕。然后还有其他时候我真的平静了很多。他们说部分原因可能是因为我经历了一次与鬼屋里通常收集数据的地方略有不同的经历。但马吉确实说过，他们发现这真的很不寻常。这是一个有点像过山车一样的GSR读数，当我们把它与我们拥有的其他人穿过鬼屋的数据进行比较时，它是非常不同的，这很有趣。
the haunted house where they normally collect data from. But Marke did say that they found this really unusual. It was a bit of a rollercoaster of a G.S.R. reading and when we look at this in comparison to other people's data that we have in going through, it's very different, which is interesting. Well, here's another theory, Maggie. Is it possible that because you were also there in a professional capacity and you were periodically stepping outside of the haunted house experience to make sure the audio was correct? You were checking in with Margie from time to time. Is it possible that switching into this cognitive mode effectively calmed you down from time
好吧，这里有另一个理论，玛吉。有没有可能，因为你当时也是以专业身份在那里，你定期跳出鬼屋体验，以确保音频是正确的？你不时地与玛吉核对。有没有可能，切换到这种认知模式实际上让你平静了下来？
to time? And that's why we're seeing this up and down spike in the data. Yeah, that totally squares with the experience I had. And I also think in general, it's so comforting going through a scary experience with another person and having Margie there and being able to check in with her really helped me. What was really sweet is Margie said that she sees this all the time. It really brings strangers together to go through a haunted house together. It makes couples feel closer, it makes friends feel closer. So there's this lovely bonding quality that is kind of like the upside of this experience. This data showing that when couples go on a first date and they meet at a
随着时间的推移。这就是我们看到数据中出现这种上下波动的原因吗？是的，这完全符合我的经历。而且我也认为总的来说，和另一个人一起经历恐怖的体验是如此令人安心，有玛吉在那里，能够和她核对真的对我有很大帮助。最贴心的是，玛吉说她一直都能看到这一点。这确实让陌生人聚在一起共同经历一个鬼屋。它让情侣感觉更亲密，让朋友感觉更亲密。所以有一种可爱的连结品质，有点像是这种体验积极的一面。这些数据表明，当情侣去进行第一次约会并在一个
very scary place, they end up feeling closer to one another than if they meet in a very boring and ordinary place Yeah, I could totally see that I actually had to apologize to Margie at one point because I held her hand All right, very professional of you Maggie. Yeah, she's a good sport about it So I assume that the fact that you made a friend Means that you're gonna forgive me for putting you through the trauma of going through a scarehouse. I don't think you're gonna get off the hook quite that easily, Junker. I think it's time that we turn the tables. I think it's your turn to get scared. What do you have in mind?
非常恐怖的地方见面时，他们最终会比在一个非常无聊和普通的地方见面时感觉彼此更亲密。是的，我完全可以理解这一点。我甚至在某个时刻不得不向玛吉道歉，因为我握了她的手。好吧，你可真专业，玛吉。是的，她对此很大度。所以我假设你交到一个朋友的事实，意味着你要原谅我让你经受了穿过惊吓屋的创伤？我不认为你能这么轻易地脱身，尚卡尔。我想是时候轮到我们风水轮流转了。我想轮到你害怕了。你有什么打算？
We're gonna find out right after this break. So this is still the Hidden Brain Podcast and I'm still Shankar Vedenthan, but I no longer feel like the host of this program. Maggie Penman brought me down to this basement studio at NPR. Maggie, what are we doing here? Mwah-haha. So Shankar, after the whole ordeal that you put me through, I think it's only fair for me to turn the tables and scare you, but unfortunately,
我们将在这次中场休息后揭晓。所以这依然是《隐藏的大脑》播客，我依然是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，但我不再觉得自己是这个节目的主持人了。玛吉·彭曼把我带到了NPR的这个地下室录音室。玛吉，我们在这里做什么？穆哈哈。所以尚卡尔，在你让我经历了一场浩劫之后，我觉得我风水轮流转来吓吓你是公平的，但不幸的是，
I'm not a very intimidating person. So, I've enlisted the help of my friend, Barry Gordamer. He's a senior producer at Morning Edition and also a magician and he's been on this program before. Welcome, Barry. Thank you very much. I'm looking forward to intimidating you. You have long played the muscle in many experiments.
我并不是一个很有威慑力的人。所以，我请来了我的朋友巴里·戈达默（Barry Gordamer）的帮忙。他是《晨间新闻》（Morning Edition）的高级制作人，也是一名魔术师，他以前也上过这个节目。欢迎，巴里。非常感谢。我很期待吓唬你。你长期以来在许多实验中都扮演着“肌肉男”的角色。
Yes, and look at that bicep. It's pretty impressive. What are we going to do, Barry? Shankar, I have with me an envelope that I'd like to give to you. Thank you, Barry. What does the envelope say? The envelope has the word prediction written in a red felt pen. Yes, and we're going to do it with a deck of cards. Okay.
是的，看看那个二头肌。相当令人印象深刻。我们要怎么做，巴里？尚卡尔，我手里有一个信封，我想把它交给你。谢谢你，巴里。信封上写着什么？信封上用红色的毡尖笔写着“预测”这个词。是的，我们要用一副扑克牌来做这个。好的。
What I want you to do is pick the card that has been predicted in that envelope. There's only a small problem, Barry. I don't know what card has been predicted in the envelope. Well, that's because you don't have the proper motivation. What we have to do is put your mind in the right place so you can concentrate and use your superior mental abilities.
我要你选出信封里预测的那张牌。只有一个小问题，巴里。我不知道信封里预测的是哪张牌。嗯，那是因为你没有适当的动机。我们要做的就是把你的心思放在正确的地方，这样你就能集中注意力并发挥你卓越的心智能力。
What do you have in mind? I have here a plate and a can of whipped cream. What are you doing here Barry? What Barry? What are you doing? Well the idea is very simple. Should you fail in this task, it will be Maggie's job to hit you in the face with this whipped cream pie. Maggie you are not going to do that. Well I don't know Shankar, you heard me in that face with this whipped cream pie.
你有什么打算？我这里有一个盘子和一罐鲜奶油。你在这里做什么，巴里？巴里？你在干什么？嗯，这个主意很简单。如果你在这个任务中失败了，玛吉的工作就是用这个奶油派砸你的脸。玛吉，你可不能那样做。嗯，我不知道，尚卡尔，你听到了我……用这个奶油派砸你的脸。
Maggie, you are not going to do that. Well, I don't know, Shankar. You heard me in that haunted house. I'm a little upset right now, so. I have to say, I feel extremely focused right now. Very good. But actually, let me help your decision process a little bit. May I have five seconds on the clock, please?
玛吉，你可不能那样做。嗯，我不知道，尚卡尔。你在那个鬼屋里听过我叫了。我现在有点心烦意乱，所以。我不得不说，我此刻感觉极其专注于此。很好。但实际上，让我稍微帮帮你做决定。请给闹钟五秒钟时间，好吗？
Oh, dear. That's one right there? Yes, that's the one right there. Okay, keep your finger on the card. Alright, so I picked a card, so I, Maggie, I would really appreciate it if you didn't bring the plates up. Shankar, will you open the envelope, please? Alright, I'm extracting a sheet of paper that was in the envelope, and it says Shankar
哦，天哪。那是其中一张吗？对，就是那张。好的，把你的手指按在那张牌上。好吧，我选了一张牌，所以，玛吉，如果你能不把盘子拿上来，我会非常感激的。尚卡尔，请你打开信封好吗？好吧，我正在抽出信封里的一张纸，上面写着“尚卡尔
will pick the eight of hearts. Now let's see if it matches the card you picked. Maggie, stand by with a pie. Shankar, turn over the card. Oh no! It's the eight of hearts. Fummer. What?
将选择红桃8”。现在让我们看看它是否与你选的牌相匹配。玛吉，拿着派待命。尚卡尔，把牌翻过来。哦，不！是红桃8。太糟糕了。什么？
How did I pick this card, Barry? First of all, sorry to disappoint you, Maggie. I was really looking forward to that. The reason you picked the card is you fell into my little trap. I used fear to cloud your judgment just a little bit. And you're saying that somehow shaped which card I picked? Exactly.
巴里，我是怎么选到这张牌的？首先，很抱歉让你失望了，玛吉。我真的很期待那个。你选这张牌的原因是你落入了我的小圈套。我用恐惧稍微模糊了你的判断力。你是说这不知何故影响了我选哪张牌？正是如此。
If I could introduce a little bit of tension into the moment with the pie and also with the deadline clock, that would inhibit your ability to make an analytical choice and force you into a snap decision that greatly increases the odds that my trick will succeed. So what I find really fascinating about this barrier is that I feel like the same thing happened to you Maggie when you were at Scarehouse, your critical thinking skills just simply
如果我能通过派以及倒计时闹钟在这一刻引入一点紧张感，那就会抑制你做出理性选择的能力，并迫使你做出仓促的决定，从而大大增加我的魔术成功的几率。所以关于这个障碍，我觉得真正引人入胜的是，我觉得你在惊吓屋时，玛吉，也发生了同样的事情，你的批判性思维能力简直
shut down. Yeah, this is exactly what Margie was telling us about. It actually makes people feel better to go through a haunted house, because they can't think about the things they've been worrying about anymore. I can't say I feel better already, but Barry, thank you for showing us that magic trick. I feel better if you were wearing that green pie. I feel better if I were eating the cream pie. Hidden Brain is produced by Karma Garkaleson and Maggie Penman, special thanks this week to
关闭了。是的，这正是玛吉一直在告诉我们的。经历鬼屋实际上能让人感觉更好，因为他们不再去想那些一直让他们担忧的事情了。我不能说我已经感觉好多了，但巴里，谢谢你给我们表演这个魔术。如果你戴着那个绿色派，我会感觉更好。如果我正在吃奶油派，我会感觉更好。《隐藏的大脑》由卡尔·加卡莱森和玛吉·彭曼制作，本周特别鸣谢
Margie Carr, Greg Siegel, and all the actors at Scarehouse and resident NPR Magician Barry Gordimer. Be sure to check us out on Facebook and Twitter. We're also on Instagram. We want to see all of your funny, spooky, nerdy Halloween costumes. Use hashtag hidden brain on your posts. I'm Shankar Vedanthan, and believe it or not, this is NPR. and believe it or not, this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
玛吉·克尔、格雷格·西格尔、惊吓屋的所有演员以及NPR常驻魔术师巴里·戈达默。请务必在Facebook和Twitter上关注我们。我们也在Instagram上。我们想看你们所有有趣、诡异、极客的万圣节服装。在你的帖子上使用标签#hidden brain。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，信不信由你，这里是NPR。信不信由你，这里是NPR。这一集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。